he's an American actor and film producer
he gained worldwide fame for his
starring roles in Star Wars and the
Indiana Jones trilogy his career spanned
six decades and includes roles in
several Hollywood blockbusters he's
Harrison Ford and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
one is my personal favorite and make
sure to stick around all the way to the
end for some special bonus clips also as
Harrison is talking if he says something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well
there was there was a guy named Mike
Nichols who a great film director he was
half of Nichols in May great stage
director one of the smartest guys I ever
met and funny hugely funny guy but the
occasion of one of my some early success
or attachment to somebody else's success
which is really what's common success he
said to me don't let them turn you into
a thing no I don't still didn't know
exactly what that means now do I but
it'll come to you I took all these years
well I mean you know somebody will
approach you with something that is not
who you are or what you want to be but
has a utility to them or perceived
utility to them and that I'll call that
a thing look your worshipfulness let's
get one thing straight I take orders
from just one person me we met doing a
Merton graffiti I was introduced to him
I actually wasn't introduced to him I
was there was a casting call for a
character in American Graffiti and
George Lucas was some guy sitting in the
back of the room and never said anything
and I got
I got a call from the casting director
and the producer of the film a guy named
Fred ruse and he said George would like
you to play a part in American Graffiti
I said how much he said four hundred and
eighty five dollars a week and I said
you got to be kidding I'm a carpenter I
have a job I make like 16 bucks an hour
you I can't I can't take the cut in pay
I got I got a kid to feed ugh 485 bucks
and I hung up and they called back in
about two or three hours and Fred said
we've been going through the going
through the budget with Gary Kurtz and
we found a little bit more money for you
and we really said how much he said $500
I said I'll take it
[Music]
the satisfaction for me comes in small
doses it comes from from a day's work I
go to work we have a job to do we've got
a bit of story to tell they've got 200
people to work with you do your job and
you feel you know the satisfaction of
hard work and application and all the
rest of the good things that work is and
then you know you go away and come back
and do it the next day so for me the
whole pleasure of acting is the work
itself sure the day-to-day work of of
collaborating with people trying to get
a story
up on the screen what's your operating
number the only advice I've ever offered
young actors is is to try and figure out
how to do it for yourself never be
caught with the with the idea that that
you can imitate someone else's success
as much as you might admire what someone
else does
don't try and imitate that find your own
way
find what find your own voice find your
own feelings and that will make will
give you a unique opportunity you are a
philosophy major in college do you have
a philosophy by which you live today I
don't think I don't think I have
something that's pronounceable as a as a
philosophy do you believe in the force
when it was fashionable to say may the
force be with you
I always said force yourself
now it's fashionable again well I'll say
again then the forces within you force
yourself look I ain't in this for your
revolution man I'm not in it for you
princess I expect to be well paid I'm in
it for the money
so are there times when you feel like
you're gonna take a chance and do
something that that might not work but
it's so good that you want to do it it
was like with 42 was that an example of
something that you thought was slightly
risky but you really wanted to do it
it's risky every time you out yeah yeah
if it's been a great success and you do
it
Indiana Jones movie and the falsehood
doesn't
it's not ambitious enough the risk is it
you know will you defend this group of
people that are very that have best
what the
there was something that was important
so you know I think there's a nerve
there's a risk every time I'm making a
massive yourself it's that something I
mean this is this is not a business
where you get to hide your there you
show up it's your face it's your
reputation it's your life get off my
plane but shortly after overcoming the
the problem of fear I became really
intrigued in in in figuring out how to
tell stories and I felt a sense of
community with the people I was working
with that I had never really felt before
in in in my life I was always kind of a
loner and I wasn't a sports guy I wasn't
a student council kind of guy so I I
felt useful in storytelling and I felt
fulfilled by it and so that's something
I thought I ought to give a give a shot
[Music]
basically what success meant to me was
the opportunity to be useful so somebody
else you know might entertain me as a as
a choice but it also meant that I could
I could use that event of a success to
do something different than what was
expected I could go to another genre I
could go to another kind of role I could
go from the success of witness to the
opportunity of Mosquito Coast right and
and and people say wait a minute
you know might not be the best career
choice and I thought well I don't have
to make the best career choice I have to
make a choice that will challenge me and
then be interesting for me what are you
looking at I know what I'm doing as your
process is an actor changed over the
years well it I have learned from each
experience you know what what works
better than something else so I think
experience helps it has helped me I
didn't really know what I was doing when
I started so it took a while for me to
figure it out did I help you in playing
this role as a CEO experience I think
all of the experience I've had in life
both in the film work and outside of it
as helps helps to prepare me to think
about
a different kind of character I got a
bad feeling about this
[Music]
that damn music follows me everywhere
it's played every time I walk on a stage
every time I walk off a stage it's worse
than that was playing in the operating
room when I went in for my colonoscopy
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you see that what that picture
of you cute
[Applause]
have you ever seen a ghost no what's
your favourite swearword
[Applause]
it appears to be everyone's a celebrity
other than you that your wife has a
crush on you hell is something that you
do that embarrasses your kids come home
if they made a movie about your life
what would it be called Oh
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Prince J asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of the top 10 rules had
the biggest impact on you and why what
did you learn what changes are you gonna
make how did you see the world now in a
different way leave in the comments and
I will join in the discussion and
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Mason Larson Mason bought 10 copies
of my book thank you so much for that
Mason those are you watching if you want
your chance at a shadow in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon
my question is regarding you being known
as a somewhat private person in real
life whether that has ever affected your
ability as an actor to extend to your
character that intimate side of yourself
that we all sort of strive to give to
each character we portray no I'm a
private person in my private life in my
working life I expect to grant my
audience complete and total access
everybody's got a backstage pass you
know you have to be willing to live in
front of people
live in front of people let them see the
good the bad the ugly the weak the
strong the conflicted
the terrible one of the things about
acting that I that gives me the greatest
satisfaction is the opportunity for that
emotional exercise that investment to
the point where it produces true emotion
it's not about you again
it's about your the continuity between
you and the rest of your race
it's about being human and it's about
sharing that humanity and and knowing
that humanity it's among some of the
most important moments of my life you
know I think ambition and passion and an
unique point of view is really important
and fuels artists especially but I the
you know the one thing I can say is find
a way to be useful find a way to not
insist on your dream include your dream
include other people in be useful to the
process that you want to be part of
don't disdain it make it work for you
make you work for them and then you'll
be you'll find it a lot easier to be to
work your way into the system so find a
way to be useful I don't have an
ambition for particular roles I have an
ambition to do good work with good
people tell stories that are compelling
and emotional and to engage my own
ambitions to do
good work that's my that's my goal for
my professional life the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]